hi everyone what's Justine hello we're
here at the LA Zoo it's the holidays so
clearly when I can't tell I've been
really sick for like a week and a half
so hadn't really films or blogged much
but I was just uh you know bring you
guys along for the ride I've got a
pretty crazy lens on right now it's a
prime so basically that means I can't
zoom so it's super fixed so it's this is
all we got
where's the super Ed's birthday and
there's rain gear
[Music]
I saw a dinosaur down there
right there dinah big dinosaur what was
your birthday when like today today
listen I'm open haha bedroom I wonder if
edible oh my god like didn't I guess
Nathan drew this yes gift it Wow
[Music]
you
jingle bells Oh jingle bells jingle
bells jingle bells go all the way
[Music]
we found the rough Hoffman who's afraid
of things the spiders and stuff I'm just
not a big fan of layer why not this is a
nice sit this is a nice bench
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys don't going so today we are
doing something super exciting we are
gonna head in and we are gonna buy a
bunch of toys for Children's Hospital
now I love the holidays but I really
love giving gifts actually way more than
receiving them so we are gonna go and
get tons of kids for the Children's
Hospital Los Angeles we're gonna go
deliver them they have a whole list of
things that you can get for kids you get
the things on the list and you take them
and you drop them off so that's we're
gonna do I've got my shopping cart
rigged up with GoPros so this is gonna
be something else let's fill up the cart
fill the card up buttercup baby don't
you have about an hour to shop and we
want to take these to the Schillings
hospital tonight to donate if you're
some of the items that they need the
most generic coloring books baby dolls
crayons interactive music alt all of
these things and we're gonna get as many
as we can
present that little cube we gotta go
close here Wow yeah let's go coloring
book
I
[Music]
and golden stars
for me
Oh
[Music]
you're making so much progress I see
colouring books crap
okay we need some first aid kits and
we've got a lot of stuff I think this is
like pretty much we almost hit
everything on the list
nice this is mine that's pretty good and
my niece oh this is actually really cool
how are you active ease up easily
he's like cool gave you like patterns
those look intense look hello kitty
got'em get a little kick one great pic
got all the items ellipses in the park
[Music]
my
can I
maybe got it and now we come about a
half hour to hopefully drop this stuff
off processing there's hope for the best
and give our toys to the kids
I'll put a link in the description where
you guys can donate to Children's
Hospital if you're in Los Angeles but if
you're not all I'd the tour was a Google
block into the toy drive and there's so
many operating are you some people just
drop off the toys that's it so movies
are helping guys like oh my gosh and he
was telling me that stuff that they
don't use with the holidays you guys are
should be throughout the whole yeah yes
so this is actually going into our
general Pulis employs and we distribute
to patients and clinics year round so we
treat over 500 but 528 thousand patients
a year
we go through a lot of toilets so cool
and then there's even like a little
picture you showed about the shell fell
through the door yeah that's beautiful
temporary wall looks so amazing my
eating oh you look great but then like
yeah that's the funny you guys do this
year round so if anybody else wants to
drop stuff off they can just find more
informational website absolutely you can
visit each late org slash
donate toys I believe and you can find
out all about our toy drive efforts our
toy needs are year-round we treat over
five hundred twenty eight thousand
patients a year so we actually meet toys
year-round books so our effort this most
of our toys come into in the holidays
but then they last probably usually talk
about August or so then we're running
low in August September so cool they
told our garage this is a great very
very really appreciate it and Happy
Holidays
so these donate our toys it was actually
so easy like we bought them drove up
here stuck them in a bin and that was it
so if you guys want to do it I'll put a
link again in the description we had to
check it out and I'm sure there's tons
of local places for you guys that you
can examine and wherever you're from so
okay
my characters so let's go we need to do
a battle
I want to do a light side battle for you
I have to go back and eat all these and
hard so that I can earn shards from them
just that in here I'm gonna clear my
squad I'm gonna go through these white
ones all right so we're gonna do chewy
and